so we have the latest jobs numbers and
once again the latest jobs report has
missed expectations but I want to talk
about it specifically in order really to
have a conversation I want to make more
of an effort to go beyond just the
latest numbers and to really make sure
we're understanding the big issues that
are underlying these jobs numbers and
the systemic economic problems that are
going to have to be solved if we're
really going to progress as a society
and progress as an economy for the sort
of betterment and well-being of
everybody in the country on the planet
whatever so as a starting point let's
quickly deal with the knob and the
numbers themselves new jobs again have
slowed down they fell short of expected
numbers in May only seventy five
thousand jobs were added in May the
expected number was 175,000 so number
one it's really important to understand
that because more and more people live
in the United States over time and based
on their ages the number of working age
people also fluctuates but as a really
general idea you need to create some new
jobs just to keep up with population
growth there are different estimates of
what that number is I've seen as low as
80,000 jobs a month I've seen as high as
a hundred and twenty thousand jobs a
month it's of complex and pretty widely
contested number and I know no matter
what number arrange I give some people
are going to disagree with me but
understand the concept
if 75,000 new jobs were created and you
need 80 thousand or a hundred thousand
or 120 thousand just to account for
population growth we're falling behind
one way or the other the only debate is
how much are we falling behind when we
only create 75,000 jobs now the trend
line is also a concern because we got
below expected numbers for several
months in a row the numbers from March
were revised down from the initial
reports March was initially reported at
189 thousand and then the numbers were
fine-tuned and we found out it was
actually a hundred and fifty three
thousand new jobs in March which isn't
great April was reported as two hundred
and sixty three thousand it was
fine-tuned and then it turns out it was
actually only two hundred and twenty
four thousand new job
so unemployment is at a historically low
rate new job numbers are falling short
of expectations regularly now payrolls
have ticked up slightly but less than
inflation which is an important metric
to consider so if we step back and we
say how is the Trump jobs economy it's
more or less the trendline that we saw
under Obama with some slowdown it's
basically a very similar trajectory
except it is slowing down to some degree
now how much of it is because of Trump
some but not all some of what Donald
Trump has done is already certainly
having an effect on the broader economic
conditions and then stepping back from
that there's sort of like a broader
geopolitical circumstance that exists
not in a vacuum but sort of on a
continuum and that has carried on from
the Obama presidency into the Trump
presidency now let's get to the really
important stuff because everything I've
told you so far it's important to know
but tracking these numbers will not and
does not address the real problems that
we have in the United States around
working and labor and wages I'll give
you an example here's a problem a ton of
work in our economy is assigned no
economic value and is treated as such
which has a whole number of different
effects so if you stay home to raise
kids or you take care of elderly parents
instead of working or you volunteer in
work that strengthens our communities in
ways that don't have a specifically
assigned economic value but obviously
have value to the economy if kids aren't
raised in a good way to use a really
sort of vague general term if kids
aren't raised in a way that makes them
good members of our communities that has
an economic cost they are more likely to
commit crime which costs money in terms
of police and property damage and
whatever else so you can understand how
raising kids properly has an economic
value but it's hard to exactly assign a
number to it and if you can't do that in
our economy its effect
valued at zero that's a major problem
that's not addressed by looking at did
we have a hundred and fifty thousand or
two hundred thousand jobs created issue
number two even when we look at wage
growth whether we have zero point two
percent wage growth or five percent or
we annualized it two three four or five
percent wage growth or whatever and we
look at the numbers over the last 40
years what you have to understand is
that the lion's share of the mean wage
growth that has taken place over the
last many decades has gone
disproportionately to the top almost all
of the economic gains since 1980 have
gone to the top half of earners rather
than the bottom half of earners a ton of
it has gone to the top one percent a
crazy disproportionate amount has gone
to the top 0.1% so you can argue about
Trump has 0.5 percent wage growth and
Obama had 0.4 or whatever but if most of
it goes to the rich it's not stimulating
the economy as much as it could it's
making society more unequal which
increases crime and all sorts of other
problems that needs to be solved so the
point I'm trying to make to you is that
bragging about we're up 0.2 percent in
wages or the unemployment rate has
ticked up or down 0.1 percent or 150,000
versus a hundred and sixty thousand job
creation it doesn't deal with these
long-term systemic problems that when
members of Congress are reelected every
two years when president's re-elected
every four years and senators are
reelected every six there is no sort of
a baseline incentive to actually deal
with that and by the way the political
battle over the jobs reports doesn't
touch inequality it doesn't touch work
that's valued at zero by the economy and
none of it deals with automation and
technological unemployment and the fact
that we're going to have to rethink
human relationships to work there are a
ton of ideas around how do we think
about a technological unemployment and
automation and robotics and artificial
intelligence we've heard about universal
basic income
we've heard about government-guaranteed
jobs programs negative income tax rates
the most important question is going to
be who gets the gains from technology if
nothing changes in our economic system
and we know the answer the huge
corporations and the rich people who buy
the robots and the automation technology
and the artificial intelligence
infrastructures they are going to get
the gains which is going to make the
country more unequal it's not going to
do demand-side stimulus meaning giving
people money that they can spend imagine
a company with a hundred employees and
the technology that lets them double
productivity there are lots of ways to
distribute the gains a pure capitalism
solution might be the company fires 50
people and they're able to keep
producing the same amount of stuff with
half the employees because of this great
technology it's terrible for the economy
fifty people are now out of a job they
don't have money with which they can go
and buy things from other companies so
those other companies that want to be
selling stuff to those 50 people lose
out and those other companies end up
having to let people go so that's not
good like a pure free market capitalism
solution for technological unemployment
and automation technology is not good
the employer could also say instead of
firing 50 people will keep all hundred
people but now with this new technology
that doubles productivity each employee
only has to work 20 hours a week instead
of 40 hours a week and they can all keep
making the same amount of money and the
capitalists so to speak the ownership
the business doesn't get any of the
gains now companies aren't going to do
that a fair solution would be that the
company gets a little bit of those gains
because they're buying the new
technology but the workers also get some
of it I don't know exactly what the
numbers would be but that would be sort
of a solution from the world of social
democracy but as you can see there has
to be regulation in order to prevent the
company from just taking all the gains
and firing half of their workforce and
that's just one of the problems that
needs to be solved so my message to you
today is that we can't take any
politician seriously that isn't talking
about the deeper issues job creation
numbers unemployment rates wage growth
these ideas of we're gonna bring back
manufacturing these are surface issues
that if we solve are effectively
band-aids in our economic system if a
candidate isn't talking about
restructuring the economic system
changing the relationship of humans to
work dealing with inequality in a
serious way dealing with the economic
activities that are not valued at all by
our current economy and then also by the
way dealing with activities that are
profitable for lots of people but
actually aren't economically valuable if
you look at a ton of what the financial
world's derivative instruments and
speculation do they can't actually be
taken seriously as drivers of economic
value in a long-term way a lot of that
stuff that's going on on Wall Street
merely serves to enrich people without
actually providing any stimulus to the
economy so if politicians aren't talking
about that stuff if they're talking
merely about I'll bring back of
manufacturing jobs or whatever else I
don't take them seriously and you
shouldn't take them seriously either let
me know what you think I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show